et is here with American Express at the
launch event for its new gold card you
are a star on glow and now are you're a
gorgeous lady on the go tell us why it's
important for you to partner with
American Express gold card and how it
makes your busy lifestyle easier oh my
gosh in so many ways there are so many
great rewards that you get for dining
and travel which are two of my favorite
things you get four times the rewards
points when you're eating out at
restaurants which my husband and I love
to do you also get four times the
rewards points when you're shopping at
grocery stores my husband loves when I
cook for him and he's also such a great
sport when I cook something that doesn't
taste the best when I try out a new
recipe he's on a break oh my god he
loves it and then I feel super proud and
then I take a bite and it's like wah wah
tell me about your bucket list place to
go with your husband oh wow um you know
Greece has been on the list for a long
time we've yet to go there for all you
foodies and jet setters who love to get
rewards head over to American Express
comm slash Amex gold to learn more
[Music]